just tell me what caused the nexus event
on lamentas let me say this again
i'm not going to tell you just so you
can turn around immediately afterwards
and prune me what's up everybody carlos
here could the most powerful nexus event
of all
be love some great mobius moments some
heavy themes and some exciting reveals
a lot goes down in this episode of loki
so yeah big bad spoiler alert folks this
is et canada's nerd alert
[Music]
there's our variant on the authority of
the timekeepers i hereby arrest you for
crimes against the sacred timeline
reset it
we know based on the last episode that
sylvie has been running from the tva
basically her whole life
episode 4 gives us a glimpse at what led
her to become the sylvie we know and how
ravana was instrumental in that
it's not a lot but it's enough for us to
know how cruel the tva really is
all while it claims to be the ultimate
protector of sacred peace
and order meanwhile in the present or
is it the future for the past anyways
sylvia and loki are seemingly about to
meet their
analymentis when an unexpected moment
occurs
okay that's not someone stepping on the
wrong leaf
you ever seen a branch like that no
this connection between them becomes a
major nexus point that gets the
attention of mobius and
inadvertently saves our heroes from
destruction
by having them captured by the tva later
in the episode after loki spent some
time getting his ragnaroks busted by the
long missing lady sif
excellent cameo by the way a plus mobius
teases loki about the moment on lamentus
saying he fell in love with a version of
himself
two variants of the same being
especially you
forming this kind of sick twisted
romantic relationship
that's pure chaos that could break
reality it's breaking my reality right
now
what a incredible seismic narcissist
you fell for yourself was it love and if
so
what kind of love if we're looking at
this show carrying the theme of
self-discovery and acceptance
then loki having love for a variant of
themselves can be read as a great
metaphor for loving oneself
but if it is a romantic love then what
does that mean
is it a sort of confirmation that sylvie
is not a loki i mean she never wants to
be called one
perhaps the next event in her timeline
was that she was adopted into asgard and
in her timeline no loki
actually exists i don't know with that
said
i don't really dig the idea of them as a
couple i'm sorry it's true i
i feel like there's gotta be more to
this relationship than that
while we'll have to wait and see on all
those theories we don't have to wait any
longer for mobius and hunter b-15 to
accept
that the tva and their own existences
have been a lie
this leads to mobius proving he is a
good guy after all as well as the most
heartbreaking scene in the series
anyone that wanted to see him on a jet
ski
you know where i go if i could go
anywhere
wherever it is i'm really from and
wherever i had a life before the tva
came along who had a jet ski
that's what i like to do just riding
around on my jet ski
prune him
as for 100 b15 she gets her moment when
she turns against the tv in this
episode's climactic battle scene
[Music]
no no that's not just here
for all time always
that's the one yeah sorry about that
this also leads to another revelation
pay no attention to the man behind the
curtain the almighty all-knowing time
keepers
are actually androids and i don't think
george washington will ever be the same
if all that wasn't enough loki then gets
pruned too but hold on
he ain't dead yet again apparently
getting pruned doesn't mean death
because our favorite god of mischief
somehow ends up in a post-apocalyptic
nyc face to face with kid loki
alligator looking loki with a hammer and
richard e grant as og old man loki
it's real it's happening it's wearing
the old school yellow and green comic
suit and it makes me
very happy now what timelines are all
these loki's from and how did they get
here
also if pruning doesn't equal death does
that mean mobius
still has a chance to ride the jet ski
off into the sunset
time will tell my friends
[Music]
now before we wrap here one quick note
on that opening scene in the episode
the tva stealing a child from their home
destroying it to erase her history and
making her mere existence a crime
is a pretty powerful allegory for the
violence that governments and religions
perpetrate on people to this very day
to be honest i wasn't prepared for this
show to go so hard into it maybe it's me
reading into it but you know what i'm
glad i did and i'm impressed that the
show did it
looking forward to seeing where it goes
from here now what did you think of this
very revealing episode
let's talk about it in the comments
below i'll see you next time